you guys should come out we'll have a
barbecue yeah when you get all moved in
I guess Janelle living in this trailer
wouldn't be too far off of the mobile
home that we lived in with Cody and me
and Janelle and Christine when you're
living in a three-bedroom
mobile home with three wives it just
gets it's very you have to have a lot of
patience
and you have to be very aware of your
surroundings
all right lovelies let's say goodbye
because I have somewhere to go you guys
are the best good luck this is fun I'm
just so nervous for Janelle I'm just so
nervous for Janelle I hope it works for
her I don't want to be a downer at all
for her but gosh
I just don't think Cody's gonna like it
there at all just saying it
he loves his routines and his Comforts
and a bigger house
and it's just like another excuse to
stay at Robin's house sorry
Robin makes it convenient for me to be
there she uh you know enforces my
relationship or reinforces my
relationship with my children okay see
you guys later
congratulations on your news yes thank
you nice I know that Janelle and Cody
have had a lot of tension through the
last year year and a half because of
kovid is this going to be something that
brings them together because they're
working together on this RV or is it
going to be something that you know
they're frustrated he's frustrated that
this got chosen I just keep praying for
them praying that they'll get some of
this stuff figured out
see you
in plural marriage if you're not around
a lot for a wife she takes it personal
she starts to feel like a victim she
feels like plural marriage is unfair in
this case Janelle has a tiny little
kitchen and a tiny little house and a
tiny little bathroom and if I'm not
around she will start to feel like she's
marginalized
but she made choices
that are major inconvenience to me to my
lifestyle
because she wanted she wanted this RV
now I'm I'm there's an inclination for
me to go well it's I've got hot water at
Robin's house
you know why am I going to sit here and
suffer with you with your choices
the situation is and is what it is
Janelle made a choice I will accommodate
that choice as best I can and then make
my own choices
[Music]